championnats du monde 2016 quatrième et
dernière partie rapide du tie-break
carsen mène d'un point il l'emporté
brillamment avec les noirs dans la
troisième karassine s'est fait
complètement débordé avec les blancs il
y là il a encore joué sa variante qu'il
a joué tout le match et cette fois car
c'est n'a réussi à prendre les devants
et à retourner la situation en faveur
des noirs on peut dire que là quand même
ça sent bon le titre pour qu'arsène il
va sans doute garder son titre
maintenant il puisqu'il avait blanc il
reste qu'une partie est par contre si
carey qui n'arrive à l'emporter il
faudra ensuite jouer des blitz pour
enfin les départager donc c'est parti
avec carsen qu'elle est blanc et ils
jouent eux quatre la même donc là car
yakine attention qu est-ce qui va faire
beau mais voilà ça y est en fait ils
varient c'est un peu tard il prend des
risques
au moment où c'est peut-être le moins ne
pas le faire je ne sais pas en tout cas
il n'a pas le choix donc qui varient
mais est ce qu'il aurait pas dû varier
avant dans le match première fois qu'il
varie cardiaque il met du coup voyez là
vous que cette variante qu'il jouait
avec les noirs là cet espagnol il a joué
pour faire nul n'est pas pour gagner tes
relief 3d 6 et 4 2 carsen kivu
tranquillou puis on prend cavale et
prend qualif 6 f3 alors ça c'est
intéressant
il joue pas le classique qui a laissé
trois ils jouent en f3 qui contrôle 4 il
veut sans doute joué c4 et le fameux et
aux 2 marrot petit c44 étonnant qu'on
peut jouer f3 comme ça tout de suite la
sémer sûr c'est jouable et la carré qui
n'est du coup tout de suite en btcc
carsen qui lui pose des problèmes dès le
début aux 5 voilà coût normal très
certainement que les détroits et voilà
ces quatre donc là c'est fini jamais les
noirs pour jouer les simples pour gagner
que ce type de parti faut se lever tôt
comme humain à 5
poule 3 on a joué à celle qu'on
affaiblit un peu les tasses noirs ici
akkas b6 donc le fou non seulement
question de classe naturelle puisqu'ils
contrôlent une belle diagonale mais met
l'accent son cette case là à 4 qu'avait
laissé 1
on n'est jamais pressé en général avec
le tomahawk si on peut remplacer ces
pièces tranquillement parce que c'est
très très solide c'est des partis qui
sont à développement lent en général qui
a blessé trois tranquille attention puis
1,4 et est en prise de la dame du
cavalier voilà damascène qu on protège
le pion à quatre avec la dame la tour on
sort la dame sur une case active conclu
au passage le cavalier ce qui ce qui est
pas mal mais sans plus voilà d'amd 2e
des clous tout de suite ou si on sait
jamais on peut menacer avec les blancs
de joie calais des cinq pour échanger
des pièces éventuellement ça fait
réfléchir car il ya six ans il fait pas
peur
carla qui ne l'a pas peur faut deux
qu'avait laissé cinq petit rock voilà
tranquille
food et cette tombe bien il faut gagner
avec les noirs cariatides tour s'est
vite ses 8
et là coup classique dans ce type de
position gardez b4 et oui et oui la
tension fourchette d'un cavalier donc on
oblige les noirs à prendre en passant
voila apres fameuse prise en passant les
noirs prennent en passant et on reprend
du pillon b3 fameuse prise en passant
recommandé par ouï lopez dès le xvième
siècle mais qui était pas encore utilisé
par tous qui était fortement recommandée
comme comme règle de jeu par le très
grand rue lopez
voilà abondamment illustrée ensuite dam
des huit cavaliers detroit
issam surtout ses palais du pain d'idées
de cahiers des trois c'est devenu un b 4
parce qu'on a les deux cavaliers là qui
vont pouvoir les sur cette fameuse
caisse des 5
donc en cas de prisons remplace par un
autre cavalier il faut pas à reprendre
d'un pion ici voyez pourquoi parce qu'on
laisse la colonne taper sur ceux qui ont
des six voilà comme ça une tour placé là
et on peut on peut faire pression à plus
long terme ce pion des six faudra suite
avec ce fou pouvoir attaquer attaquer le
pion en tout qui tourne ensuite c'est du
long terme mais c'est un peu ça l'idée
qu'elle réussisse et voilà qu à libé 4'
pop
l'idée c'est là on vise la casse des 5
voilà on va mettre un cavalier pour
doubler et ne pas reprendre d'un pion
pour pas bloc pour pas boucher cette
faiblesse ce pur est faible il faut lui
mettre la pression vous ccist ça
explique le coût des noirs la voix la c6
l'idée c'est bien si tu viens là
j'échange si tu reproches échanges en
cours tu prends la d'hab ça reste faible
mais a plus beaucoup de pièces pour
attaquer à tour des vins voilà les
blancs se pressent pas autour des 1 on
joue qu'avec des scènes quand on veut
ici là pas de problème on masse des
pièces voilà ici on masse des pièces sur
cette colonne d en contrôler au maximum
cette case on a envie d'y aller hcl
boncourt je pense intéressant ce âge
sexe empêche des g4 les blés mûrs pour
les blancs auraient pu prendre part dont
de la vente à j'allais droit aussi en
jouant h5 on empêche cette idée là on se
donne un petit peu d'air aussi donc
c'est passé pas mal il faut enfin
tranquillement
leur place leur pièce en jouant fou et
fin bon ben je je me permet de contrôler
la deuxième je ne sais pas si c'est
intéressant je vais peut-être me mettre
ce car elle est là ici plus tard pour
aller venir en g3 et pourquoi pas un f5
ya une quasi 6 mai sur obliger les noirs
à jouer g6 bas c'est bon à chaque fois
que les noix pousse des pions on est
content ça affaiblit dès 15 h 4 voilà
alors h4 ben c'est un peu l'idée battu
viendra jamais hein tu feras jamais
qualifié 3 voilà et en plus je libère la
case h5 pour mon cavalier
alors attention les noirs ont une idée
aussi h3c protéger en plus par cette
batterie donc difficile à attaquer ce
pion quasiment impossible fouet f2 damas
il suffit de bouger le cavalier lâche 5
et ces deux pièces contrôle aussi aux
gens car il n 5 on peut venir f4 et en
cas de prisons reprend de l'autre
cavalier nous aussi on peut avec les
noirs aller sur une case avec double
cavaliers dame f2 à lord ahmed 2 l'idée
c'est pas tomber sur 100 m petit oeil
là-dessus bon il faut faire quelque
chose avec les noir sans doute
quoique ces patients parce que dame
prend car elle et prend 1,4 le cas elle
est protégée par le fou le fou attaque
la dame il faut que la dame jourdain
gagner un pion central et ça craint qu
au nom donc c'est pas tellement attaqué
ça c'est surtout avec ça et ça et bien
aux menaces de venir dès 6 voilà on met
l'accent on l'avait dit alors le fait de
jouer à 5 affaibli cette case
donc on met l'accent sur cette case andy
van damme fou b6 été obligé de partir de
là et du coup ce fut un peu moins bien
protégé aussi parce qu'il ya plus deux
pièces pour le protéger et voilà donc
des coups simples qu'elles aient des
sept voiles à 17
très bon coup cette batterie maintenant
protège 4 et en plus ce qu'elle est
cette contrôler la casse b6 et c sur les
échecs c'est simple j'ai 3 g iii il dit
ben écoute avance et on pions d'avancé
champions jusqu'en h4 bien moi je moi
aussi je vous prends de l'espace à
l'oeil droit
parce que là tu peux rien faires fait un
peu dénudée l'attaqué des pions de
lanton roi des pièces sont quand même
bien dans ton camp à l'aide d'armes je
suis très très bien je suis pas de
problème tout contretemps un peu là
colonna mais quand je veux je vous
taurin déscente est bloqué donc si je
peux créer de l'espace alain le roy ça
va on va pas comme ankara qui va gagner
ça tu auras 3-1 créé des petites menaces
petite pression ici menace de doubler
les tours peut-être fois je crois très
bon coup d'où l'idée aussi faux f1 après
j'ai trois fous h3 ce fut une magnifique
voilà une chose à ramasser au moment
opportun ici
à noter qu'on peut aussi venir en dessin
quand on veut là il y aurait pu car
c'est leur met donc le cavalier fils
avait bougé on aurait pu envahir la
caisse des siècles voilà mais les noirs
double voilà alors l'idée sans doute
sexy qu'à aider 5-fu prend ici cavaliers
prends tu contrôles plus à deux je peux
jouer tour à deux attaques la dame et je
m'active un peu calé ces deux attaques
la tour ont regardé ses cavaliers
contrôle à 4 c 3 à 4 à 3 à 2 1 toutes
les cases d'arrivée sont contrôlés par
ses cavaliers à noter aussi que on
contrôle la casse des quatre n'aurait
jamais de qualité 4 en contrôle déjà
avec dame est fou mais avec le cavaly
c'est encore mieux à 6 3 6 mois les
noirs sont passifs
et tu veux répéter les coups en avant je
suis champion du monde
si tu répètes les couches champion du
monde et la cara qui est obligé de
tenter quelque chose tu auras ces cas
les c2 v6 des six
c'est un coup ça permet de retirer le
fou peut-être je sais pas je sais pas
pourquoi je vais 6 il faut bien jouer
des coups aussi un messi ça empêche
décès c'est aussi pourquoi pas pour
jouer b 4 c 5 des choses comme ça un bbc
c'est plus dur
tours d2 tranquilles eux les blancs
protège bien la deuxième rangée on
envisage pourquoi pas de doubler les
tout encore sur la colonne des l'a peut
être pas mal dams et 7
et oui on double faux et fuite pour car
yakine qui n'a rien obtenu 1 et on
voyait que là il malgré le fait qu'ils
doivent gagner n'a pas pas réussi à
rentrer dans une variante intéressante
est celle et regarder les blancs n'ont
pas peur ici pour qu'arsène carrément
voilà il prend le pion et où il
resterait un pion éloigné a comme sa
double et là on peut se dire c'est pas
beau le problème c'est que c'est quand
même bien de plus ce plan il pu pousser
en âge 5 et 1 6 et casser le un petit
peu le roc est en même temps pourrait
jouer ouachin peut-être et tour g1 plus
tard pour aussi attaqué en tout cas
voilà on a pris le pion ça donne de
l'air la dame aussi à noter parce qu'on
peut venir en g3 on peut venir après on
peut prendre ainsi sans suite on pourra
venir angers 6 avec la dame ou angers 4
à tapis au cices voilà donc en fait les
blancs de l'air partout ils sont bien
les dames les north ne peuvent rien
faire ces cavaliers empêche toute
pénétration
le centre est entièrement bloquée donc
il crée du jeu allez le roi c'est le
blanc qui joue pour gagner là
bizarrement alors que carla qui n'en
auraient dû entrer dans quelque chose de
plus tendue il n'a pas réussi
il n'a pas réussi il peut pas revenir
dessus kf4 beaucoup attaque le fou h3 où
va se fout pas simple et
on essaie de créer des menaces en tout
cas bon coup pour essayer de gagner
parce qu'il faut bien essayer de faire
quelque chose simplement il prend car
saint paul on prend hélas simplement il
prend g7
pourquoi parce que bétonnage calais ont
été très forts en venant à 1,5
en plus cette tour peuvent coulisser sur
la colonne h le cavalier peut venir cinq
peut-être en c5 aussi attaqué b3 et
s'est passé est de protéger ou 1,5 il
est très fort tout simplement ils
attaquent f3 qui quand même un petit
pion un pion qui peut s'avérer faible
avec des problèmes
donc on élimine cette pièce qui sans
doute la plus dangereuse des noirs dans
la position d'un prend et blanc ont
regardé une position quand même
tranquille ça s'est doublée aussi donc
ça compense ce doublement l'a sans doute
et puis ça c'est tout seul voilà donc là
il ya une grosse pression avec ça tout
seul sa crème ça craint quand même on
voit pas là on sent bon le titre pour
car celle là encore calé becaert qui
revient b4 attaque c6 menace d'aller en
d5
ça permet quand même tour à trois qui
attaquent b3 ya pas trop de choix
d'ailleurs car à qui il le fait menace
de prendre p3 est là car scène prend ses
six tout simplement d'un prend hejduk et
à libé self défense indirects
intéressant en cas de tours prend b3 il
y aura câbles et des quatre attaques la
tour et la dame fourchette
oui défense indirects et on active le
cavalier on menace aussi de prendre en b
une menace de tout changer car c'est là
un peu l'idée et noir prennent quand
même
et la voilà ça traîne quand même après
qu'elles aient des quatre daims prend
avec kara qui saute sur l'occasion pour
avant une finale avec des micros une
micro asymétrie petits pions pas c'est
peut-être là et jouer sa chance
il faut qu'ils essaient de gagner donc
qui tentent d'aller prendre et 3 sans
doute s'il n'avait pas été obligée de
gagner l'aurait pas jouer ça me prend
et la dame 2 les blancs la qualité de
plus en jouant dames 2 ici bas les
blancs peuvent venir en d3 peut venir
ensuite en d4 d5 désactive leurs dames
tout simplement
2 à noter aussi que sur tours à 3
qu'attaquer f3 ménagers jouets d'un menu
je peux jouer autour des trois attaques
la dame attaque la cour alors je peux
faire les échanges fawcett attention
attention quand même la mémoire joue
bien attac h4 on peut aussi me prendra
quatre c'est déjà bien on peut aussi
venir en aide si ce pur pour contrôler
les cases ici central sinon je sais pas
si c'est bien ou pas voilà en tout cas
on dit on sort le fou pour qu'il soit
beaucoup plus actif roigé deux ont mais
le roi sur blanc pour éviter de subir un
échec dans le six en faire qu'un tout
petit peu attention mes os x lion mine
de rien il tient pour l'instant
et quand les noirs prennent avec le fou
il ya toujours tout reprend voilà alors
attention les noirs peuvent faire un
échec là mais c'est pas grave on vient
pas grand-chose h5 d'ailleurs des blancs
les blancs ne laisse pas faire h c'est
un très bon coup évidemment puisque ça
empêche d'objets six échecs tout
simplement d'un problème tour à trois
années dans sa team peu faut faire
attention
cazaux 3.93 derrière tours 3 serait
quand même embêtant donc laisse pas
faire car c'est au tour des trois tours
à deux tours d2 et wii party nul ça
m'arrange je suis champion du monde la
cie lanka deux parties nul 3-3 pour des
trains peut pas répéter car à qui donc
ils obligeront lyon cette tour des
salles qui activation menace de la tour
ça empêche la dame maintenant devenir de
ce côté ça contrôle h5 sa bouche sa
bouche les perspectives des noirs ça
contrôle aussi la classe b scène qui
contrôlait par la dame de paris tours
pour ses sets
il n'y a pas de coût pour les noirs le
problème je pourrais faire un sur tours
trois belges que jouer tour un détroit
où je peux revenir et puis je recommence
c'est cette dame des deux très simple
pression en d6 et surtout attaque f4
comment je défends
il n'y a pas beaucoup
et pas de cou en fait le seul coup c'est
d'un v6 ou encore d'un match si c'était
possible mais la dame s'y fait rien sur
la chaîne je vous rappelle qu'il est
contrôlé de toute façon les noirs sont
vissés ça sent bon le titre pour
qu'arsène tour essayent maintenant eh
oui ça y est attention sur de plomb de
retomber là maintenant damages 4
attention qui piègent encore là qu'est
ce qui se passe sur dame prend f4
attention il y aurait tour ces deux
chèques et il pourrait y avoir des
magouilles bon car ce n a pas envie de
rentrer là dedans on n'est pas pressé de
toute façon ils risquent rien là il
avait calculé mardi le pion contre la
case g4 sopi rencontres-là casier 3 la
tour contrôle tout
tout ça tout ça est tenu là par le roi
donc la dame ne peut pas faire des
chèques
il n'y a rien en fait voilà donc
simplement je vois la tour à tour c'est
à toi en cas deschamps je prends puis
après je vais gober ça et ça va être
terminé à près d'1 prend la partie
finish une qualité de plus quand même
tour à cette voie là seul coup pour
essayer de gagner pour essayer de venir
à ici faire des échecs etc
les blancs prennent en f4 ça sent la fin
ils n'ont pas peur là en prenant f4 je
protège h 2 donc finalement j'ai même
pas peur nos tours à deux échecs en
retour si auparavant j'ai quand même
activer matour qui peut venir faire un
échec on s'est vite tu auras deux échecs
ouais j'suis pas des mariages de la dame
est attaqué et le seul coup c'est d'un
raid avec deux n'a pas d'autre les deux
est là car senna tout calculer il valait
mieux parce que là ça craint un tout
petit peu quand même hein les
blanc là son tout petit peu sous
pression et quand même menace de maths
bon je peux vous dire en g3 avec la dame
mais y'a mieux regarder fantastique fin
c'est quand même beau final voilà
réfléchir un peu superbe final manade
carsen les blancs jouent égales cette
fois il aura tu pas dans la deuxième du
des portages on l'a vu il a raté un math
carsen pas vu un matin il faut aussi ces
chèques en toute fin de partie
c'est peu de temps mais là il le voit il
le voit alors qu'il est peut-être plus
dur à trouver d'ailleurs je ne sais pas
bon bref regardez c'est superbe c'est
magnifique
là c'est quand même ça conclut comme un
championnat du monde quand même pas mal
nouvelle facture car il a été très bon
on peut pas dire le contraire
il a fait douter car ce n est quand même
posé de gros soucis il a mené car c'est
la première fois je crois qu'ils aiment
ou d'un championnat du monde
regardez up échec on n'a pas peur parce
qu'attention et maintenant sinon menace
m'attendent g2 et mat avec tour à m mes
ordis il a tout calculé chorale 7 et la
superbe coup fantastique pour le failli
le voir cela allez je vous laisse 10
secondes 9 8
six cents
un boom bass da macheath échec énorme
sur l'a2 prise possible
roy prend dans ce cas la tourache huit
matches
donc faut prendre du plomb est là
cet essai bateau si tout est contrôlé
par les tours échec et le roi ne peut
pas nier en justice à cause du pion h5
superbe coup pour conclure aux
championnats du monde quand même c'est
pas mal dernier coup des championnats du
monde dames h 6 échecs avec la dame
emprise de deux façons pas protégés mais
c'est mal derrière sacrifice
d'extraction les noirs sont obligés
d'ouvrir le jeu par g prend 1,6 et tout
reprendre lors de d'enlever le roi de du
contrôle de la fuite et ils se font
mater superbe donc victoire finale de
carsen dans le tie break 2-0 après avoir
frôlé quand même un frôlé frôlé la
déception dans le match parce qu'il a
quand même pris une belle bulle en
huitième partie il a fallu qu'ils
reviennent donc il a montré d'une super
classe 1 400 je trouve un seul
championnat du monde revenir comme ça
alors qu'il reste peu de parties à la
demande presqu'un égaliser c'est très
très fort ça rappelle le grand kasparov
incapable de légaliser les championnats
du monde à la dernière partie alors
qu'ils menaient d'un point face à karpov
à séville en 87 donc cesser les plus
grands qui sont capables de ça d'avoir
les nerfs d'acier et alors que karachi
une nuit ben voilà il a un peu montré
que sa limite c'est peut-être il n'a pas
pris de risque qui ne peut jouer
toujours la même variante et il n'a pas
su en le voyant rapide il a patient qui
était une seule fois car scène en fait
qui a joué magnifiquement bien voilà
donc carsen le jour de son anniversaire
gagne son titre en 2016 enfin conserve
son titre en 2016 ça reste le champion
du monde incontesté et incontestable
numéro 1 au classement mondial il est
superbe il joue bien il est beau voilà
et donc on l'attend pour le prochain
match de championnat du monde où on
espère pourquoi pas pourquoi pas en deux
camps les derrière maxime vachier
lagrave on espère qu'il va pourquoi pas
essayer de se qualifier et de jouer une
finale qui gêneraient toute la france en
haleine on n'a pas eu de champion du
monde en france depuis peut-être
philidor est alors allée keane bien sûr
qu'ils étaient quand même français mais
bon de l'école russe quand même accepté
c'est un russe au français et à mesure
le grand champion du monde de l'histoire
où le grand meilleur joueur du monde de
l'histoire c'est quand ça reste philidor
s'est il nous ramène au xviiie siècle
est la maxime est bien
maxime il est là formé en france est
capable pourquoi pas d'aller lui aussi
prendre la place de quart jaeckin et de
jouer car ce n est d'essayer de lui
poser des soucis
il en est capable voilà merci de m'avoir
suivi sur la télé pour ce championnat du
monde 2016 il vous donnons rendez vous
donc pour deux prochains grands
événements mondiaux
bientôt donc sur sur la chaîne merci au
revoir